yeah hello welcome to this video this is
courage for round two of the sink filled
cup currently Allen sent Lewis yep this
is a bit late I've been very busy today
so i didn't manage any any earlier what
is game of the day for onto its two part
of white nakamura with black so in round
two we had done yeah we had two groups
of people those who won the first round
and those who lost the first round as we
didn't have any drawers so T'Pol of
Nakuru was a duel among those among to
head one day games so if this is having
a winner they will lead the event let's
see what happened in this game to pile
of went one year for and yeah the
buildin very popular nowadays some
something like the main line of the open
games for sure yeah Nakamura is not a
super regular Berlin player he does play
it um but it's not like his son yeah I
his exclusive weapon like you look at
Crom Knicks games he almost plays it all
of the time but the Nakamura he switches
around a little bit still something that
to power off could have expected 23
Bishop c5 and night BTW to ya an
interesting move all here for wider
early night BTW to the nuance sem a very
subtle it's some one point of that
movies um okay let me do one thing if
white castles for example then black has
this opportunity yeah it's interesting
way to play where black looks at those
two and gets to trade that night from
six which quite often is seen as an
accomplishment it's not clear that this
is like a good for black or so but well
i would have found play that i think my
experience tells me that the knight on
c6 is quite often not very well placed
and likes to be exchanged if white wants
to avoid that his
sometimes plays the move c3 which is
maybe the most popular move but in that
case white is committed to that moose
and that is not totally clear if you
really meet c3 in some cases maybe when
you want to take on c6 and get to this
kind of pawn structure yeah let me um
castles is probably losing a poem oh
yeah I care anyway I want to show what
I'm talking about this kind of structure
just ignore the fact that if I've might
be hanging well this is weak now yeah if
you want to take on c6 you want to do it
with the pawn back on c2 so c3 is giving
limiting white a little bit of that move
so night BTW to is an interesting
alternative that is not playing c3 and
not playing cancelling if black goes 94
now white can take and play Knight f3
and this is awkward you don't want to
allow the capture there and well if you
go back thats hanging on oh wait i
cannot actually take it I just I just
spotted this one okay so what is quite
going to do maybe castling then 94 might
be an idea right there is no were clear
indication why that wouldn't work yeah I
thought that this is okay but now
looking looking at it that's really not
clear okay white hands Bishop c4 it's
just a little bit different let's say
then castles anthem and c3 nakamura
played d6 and to cancel its castle so
that happened after all and those are
very transposition heavy anyway those
openings difficult also to learn to
really get get a grasp what is going on
because the the move waters are so
flexible 97 this is a modern way to play
a term that the Kimura chooses here it
um has been played amongst other spy by
chronic
the ideas that that knight on c6 is not
very well placed if you look at that
night it looks at two important squares
but they're both covered by that pawn
and quite often the night is just not
very good there so 97 trying to get it
to g6 white goes deform and the
interesting point now yes then black is
capturing and now retreating it looks a
little bit illogical at first why give
white that big Center but the thing is
black has ideas to play against that
Center on associated with maybe c6 and
d5 the right moment sometimes even f5
and we will see that idea in the game um
rookie one that looks quite normal
Nigeria that was the Knights destination
it's not to stop the only a movie there
also this also has been played in a game
between Maxim Vashti lagrave and Sega
kayaking a couple of things that have
been tried him but not g6 looks
completely completely normal h3y a move
that is played very often in the open
games here in the Italian game in the in
the Rue La Paz because white quite often
fields a little bit annoyed by that
pinning possibility so he goes age three
and back night h5 that's an interesting
way to play at trying to use that f4
square black has given up a little bit
of the center but yes decent decently
plays pieces that Bishop is putting some
pressure on there porn and blacks nights
trying to do something on the Kings side
it looked a bit more logical to me
actually to play d5 however after a five
night um I'm sorry that is just giving
away opponent this is what I wanted to
do after this it's not clear what a
black is doing with that night now yeah
if you if you go back
a move like 94 is immensely awkward yeah
intending to check that night the the
problem is if black is doing some kind
of despereaux let's say like this and
this then why'd really has said
classical Greek gift classic classic or
classical well it is well known that
Greek gift sacrifice on 87 and black
will get destroyed very quickly so this
this and then night age five is a bit
better but here it's not clear where
those nights are going night f1 and yeah
what-what exactly now hmm the nights you
will light seemed the Knights seem a
little bit misplaced there I'm sorry um
this is what nakamura played 94 Bishop
c7 and now to pile of play d 5 which
according to my information is a novelty
an interesting move we see that both
sides by the way have spent quite a bit
of time so that was not the result of
some deep preparation they really am
played it over the board the last moves
yeah d five yd five um it's a fairly
logical move on to think of it the pawn
on d5 makes sure that this pawn stays on
d6 and that this Bishop painting rather
badly him that this Bishop is just
looking at his own porn yeah black was
probably threatening to go d5 so what is
pre-empting that with his own porn push
now can we are now played the Knight to
f4 which seems quite obvious
yeah and now is an interesting moment um
Black now has a couple of options he is
absolutely not forced to do what you
know what you know played he played a
very direct very sharp move um it was f5
that Nakamura played and it seems that
after this move he is in at least in
some trouble in a practical sense um
maybe there are better options I'm not
totally sure what's best um maybe an
idea is to take on d5 and do something
like b5 and so that this Bishop might be
might be of some use on b6 it's very
complicated this position White has some
space with that pawn on d5 but um
black's pieces seem fairly active if we
think that reverses not going is either
at the corner the edge of the board are
you three blocking that Bishop let's say
we go 33 just to continue that line
Bishop d7 to cover this and now black is
ready to go like rook e8 Bishop p6 that
doesn't look too bad feels pretty
complicated and unclear to me now camera
plate f5 and this would be a really good
move if it was informed to pollow's
reply after that said reply it's not
clear that why it has a huge advantage
but it is very difficult to play let's
see what happened d5 played by two paths
that's a very strong move however if you
look at the position a little bit you'll
find out that this is also the only move
that is somehow a challenging Blackett
every other move is completely
completely harmless yeah what is the
point of i-5 it's it's rather sharp as
we see it's a breakthrough in the center
and the very simple things are things
okay this is not possible it gives away
a piece um d takes ok then white can
fuji 6 and blackheads to go back to be 8
here with that bishop after which White
has a number of interesting
continuations one simple continuation is
to just take on you five it's not clear
that it is the best continuation but i
just want to show an example let's say
takes takes him check check check check
something like that it's definitely very
promising for what one huge issue is
that the North f5 is absolutely not
fitting in have this position if black
um it's by this is just really am a pure
purely theoretical discussion let's say
because it never could have happened in
the game but for example the puppy on f6
then black would be completely okay
nothing happens but II five is just a
tremendously week squares along the dark
squares are in the center now that's
very unconventional so what did nakamura
play probably the best defense it took
with the knight on d5 and takes takes
takes takes and b3 so why it is a pawn
down and does he have enough
compensation on that that can be
answered with them quite some certainty
yes he definitely has enough and the
real question is is it more than enough
and if it is more than enough by by how
much how much better is wide and why is
he better the thing is that this bishop
on c1 currently on c1 will get a
fantastic role on the dark squares on b2
in some cases also on a three especially
on b2 we see what a diagonal yeah that
that's that's fantastic White has great
play on that diagonal Queen d4 for
example would build up that battery
threaten made or
g7 yeah like here now and queen up and
the thing is black really has huge
coordination issues se5 is so weak and
paint 85 as weak and the Holy file is
vulnerable again this is all do you like
having the pawn f5 yeah this is
relatively in the first glance minor
detail that the pawn is on f5 and not on
f6 let's say changes the position
completely here black has some some some
real trouble to get this position
coordinate it um the Karma played the
move Bishop d7 now and I think that this
is probably not not that precise I was
thinking while I'm not able to present
something that is great for black um I
was thinking you should maybe try
something like that getting this Bishop
Bishop out however white has very strong
compensation yet again it will be
something like let's say this this yeah
and Bishop c4 coming this is quite
comparable to the game but here the prom
Bishop is on f5 white has good chances
anyway but it was an alternative to what
Nakamura played Bishop be six instead
instead of this also seems some a little
bit better but it doesn't change the
verdict that white has a fantastic
compensation and this is something not
to be underestimated if sort of one side
has compensation that means that he is
materially down for something which very
often means the initiative and having
compensation and having the initiative
due to that it's very often just meaning
that the site is better because it's
easier to play it's easier to play a
forward shares and backward shares in
most cases so a very inconvenient
position for Nakamura to play Bishop 27
as I said was his choice which should be
to rook e8 Queen D for all that looks
very normal blocked with the Queen
now white of course didn't want to trade
and now get this Bishop into play now we
see how strong those bishops are
fantastic age six new blacks position
and doesn't inspire much confidence but
he wanted to control g5 at least queen
deform simply threatening mate yeah and
black is already in a situation where
his only he can only choose between
things that are somewhat worse he played
Queen f6 after which it would be a
torture and I was thinking maybe a
rookie seven maybe this is stronger
however if you look at this line tending
h5 you see that there's really really
huge pressure on leg and simple little
problem is that a move like rook to e8
here it's always always the wrong word
yeah maybe there's something better but
at least can be answered by oops not
that Jam can be answered by recapture in
their pawn and here black is just in
trouble he's not even material up for
his bad position okay so let's go back
he played Queen to f6 not a happy move
but it was only a choice between a votes
that say there wasn't anything great
anymore take stakes and Bishop takes the
black had to return a pawn but this is
now after this return of the pond equal
material and why it has the the bishop
pair in a wide open position he also has
a slightly better structure because of
that isolated f porn this is not so
relevant at the moment
the f porn cannot be put under pressure
but the bishop a alone is some cementing
white advantage and it is a very
substantial one around this position I
think somewhat later during the live
live broadcast they had a look at that
game and I am just said okay wyd will go
wide we win this and yeah this is what
um basically describes the rest of the
game let's say why does demonstrating a
technical play with the two bishops
against currently it's a night and
bishop but soonish this will change
rooty one that's an important move white
does not want to trade more pieces quite
often you want to trade more pieces when
you have the better end game because way
you may be a pawn up here you want to
simplify it at the end you said porn in
the king opponent game here it's
important to keep the pressure on and I
think exchanges probably would have
helped black to organize this defense or
so rook to you one is a a good move
Bishop 36 yeah that was tough to avoid
here actually I was thinking that King
takes f6 might be an idea now camera
took on e6 with with them with the rook
I was thinking that this could be an
idea you're getting rid of the bishop
path white might take one play and then
at least we get some kind of activity
eid five Qing Yi 50 sorry for that noise
that's my my coffee coffee maker and
yeah but your black is somewhat active
um it's not enough we have to be a
perfectly jective there but maybe it was
some better practical chance than the
cap shawnee 6 it's tough to say however
both both both um don't inspire much
confidence
and why's white secures that Ned Bishop
now we have we have two bishops against
two nights the ideal ideal distribution
um yeah Kiev one played by to Paul off
um it was interesting to play g3 as
given by the computers to look at this
square and make sure that nothing
happens there but I'm not sure how
serious it is jumped right in before I
think white is always keeping some
advantage 3 and back g3 yeah I cannot
take it because of f4 and drying
terribly and wide were why do we win
that night yeah so jump back Bishop to
f2 rube t8 blue thread rupees and 93
check one yeah and the next move is
probably helping white um I think that
he probably should have just stayed
let's say yeah with some non move king
of 6 or h5 or something now maybe rupee
folks coming kicking f6 dismay quite
some sense um this kind of move gives
black it still chances to hold this
position it's not fun at all two nights
against two bishops Israeli fun but you
have some chances to hold what he did is
he went f4 and after g4 I think white
has gained from that those two points
they might prove dangerous to get a
passport and in general advancing those
points also might help in some kind of a
tech on the King so this isn't isn't he
really helping but probably are they had
time I was speculating that there might
be some some time issue okay not that f4
is a double ? move and totally terrible
is just
I felt that not doing this probably
would have been a bit tougher right do
g5 him yeah not raiding again yeah why
of course keeps the bishop yeah he has
gotten age for in so they're gt5 is
under control right c7m black wasn't
able to take here jack no that's very
awkward to something like that so back
to c7 just try to build something on the
fortress like it was the wrong button
yeah 97 h 5 fixing that weakness on age
six that makes lots of sense then bishop
my detected King as six Gaby 5-ply get
some unleashing there on the on the
queenside trying to push that Bishop
back Jack White checks and now King g5
King g5 is a very risky move to put it
mildly um they were very difficult to do
something against this with mate we very
difficult is wrong like has ways to to
do something against it but it's all
related oh it's all comes with with the
drawbacks there is no one a good clean
solution now anymore h right why do I
took yeah but should be three or
stronger I'm sorry there was a bit
confusing and two part of took but
Bishop b3 would have been stronger what
is black doing now is king cannot move
his knights cannot move and if he does
that there's rooks you want and we have
a counter-attack going
black takes loop c5 is going to be
played and now it gets very difficult
for black to to find find anything you
can hardly move yeah the King cannot
move the night cannot move this night
cannot move what is flags move yeah it's
very difficult the rook is also tied
down something like that for example is
answered by this yeah and that decides
now you cannot look at all the lines but
after Bishop b3 yes sir it's a win it's
really a win that king of 6 move has
made things a little bit simpler to part
of ever took and played look see one
this is also winning ultimately but not
as quickly as the other line however
it's not really it doesn't really matter
you know because if you find a win in
your game and you are reasonably sure
that you will win that without any big
hassle complications or whatnot then
playing that it's not a mistake you
might have something hmmm that is
simpler also it's possible but it's no
mistake if you play something that does
win ultimately and doesn't really put
you in some kind of danger or in some
risk I mean something like the game
continuing losing on time is always
possible somehow yeah so dope olive
didn't play the strongest move with that
bit should be three but he played
something that is totally enough rookie
six oopsie five yards it has soup Swan
qualities
and 83 very nice now black is in some
kind of looks like what should he play
it's difficult you cannot move this
cannot move the king prawns don't make
much sense the rook hmm but where yeah
the only move besides what he played
played where the truck is sex yeah that
it's down you move actually yeah it's
the only move otherwise something gets
lost so rookie six and roop see one yeah
possibly getting the rook over there
under some circumstances it's a bit more
flexible there then on the fifth yeah
look see one and term
97 Bishop f24 bishop age form 83 amazing
how often mating motifs play a decisive
role in end games and g5 yeah pushing
things forward and getting getting
something going yeah g5 black doesn't
really have much he took it Bishop Keith
95 teen g4 we shouldn't forget it's
equal material but why it has some trump
cards he's got the H passer very
dangerous pawn f4 is weak the rook is
active on c1 and his Bishop will also be
the better minor piece compared to the
night so that's a very nice situation
for why that probably is winning in the
long run King g7 and why took that pond
so we've got a rogue and porn end game
in which blacks drawing chances are very
very very low the problem is that white
has two pawns f porn and h porn that
will distract black's pieces and during
that time White has opportunity to
invade on the queenside and trying to
pick up things here yeah a5 trying to
reduce the porn count but it doesn't
really help anymore oops I'm sorry y can
just take it check check yeah I know
she's gets lost and a6 being played yeah
it is a very very one-sided endgame here
and to part of this is a good job of
converting the game only lasts a couple
of mumbles check
check check yeah and that's it here um
Nakamura resigned yeah what to take from
that game um a very interesting moment
was here in the opening we had some
moves that up close to being at least
theoretically known and then black was
faced with the decision how to play here
when did went for didn't go for d5 but
for that Nabu and now nights you form
back d5 I think that what black did that
night here and now f5 is probably a bit
too risky the resulting positions are
probably not hugely favorable for white
but they are much easier to play for
what so probably due to that a 5mm it's
at least a bit risky let's say yeah then
the pawn sacrifice was strong and now
white was dominating on the dark squares
ultimately getting a very very good
middle game and then then in game where
black was pretty much helpless is quite
yeah quite interesting or revealing that
say how important this pawn movies here
if their pawn would be on f6 on f7 white
would have very little compensation very
little compensation but here it is
really substantially strong what white
handsome is going with his bishops yeah
that was the the game of the the second
round there were a couple of other
interesting games agree shock beat vishy
anand with white you know in a nice
interesting game there were a couple of
short draws I will note was there an
additional decisive result currently a
little bit mystified let me check
yeah of course mother's cousin he played
with black against fabiano caruana and
and of course that sounds like a great
pairing and it was an interesting game
however that game was completely decided
on a huge time scramble by both sides
and therefore also the move that both
players played in that time travel were
pretty questionable and I didn't want to
look at that game so closely because
we're essentially talking about it
almost a bullet game at the end from the
time that they had left and nobody wants
to seriously analyze Game Center plate
without that shorter time available for
the players it's just got not very young
very nice to show let's say what kind of
blunders they played in the in the time
scrum but however if you again get a
video of that it's quite entertaining to
watch after a bit to a great players and
struggling there with the time control
ok the next video will be em on for
round 3 and that will be much much
quicker compared to compare compared to
that but yeah I'm optimistic that i will
be more on time in the in the future
because lots of things that I had to do
are done yeah I was kind of a little bit
redesigning if you want my my setup at
home yeah what some some furniture I I
exchanged and yeah got rid of lots of
technical stuff that I don't don't need
anymore and all that costs enormous time
but I'm now like almost done on 90
something percent I guess with all what
I wanted to do so I'm more flexible now
and quicker in doing the round reports
the game of the day videos forcing [ __ ]
up okay well thanks for watching guys
till tomorrow off yeah tomorrow is
probably wrong until the next video